bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get into
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got
anthony here with me uh you know that he
is
mother was a very intelligent person
because she absolutely named
anthony which is the greatest name in
the american language so
thanks so much for doing this man it's
great to be here and
it's definitely anthony and not tony i'm
the same way
all right uh let's uh let's just start
with uh with kind of your background
where'd you grow up and uh how did you
get into uh business technology and
investing
sure uh i was building computers when i
was about eight years old
i was born in 1975 so my my dad brought
home a computer
when i was about she's about
82 83 and ibm pc junior and
and this was really the dawn of personal
computing and i was just hooked that was
my thing all through through school that
was the thing that i got taken away from
me when when i did something bad
um so i just became a computer guy i was
building computers when i was about 10
or 11 i was
working with a family friend doing
networking at schools
so just just immersed in in in computers
and then
before the internet came about i was on
modems and communicating with people on
vbs boards and
so that was the the common thread for me
as a child that in sports i grew up
playing hockey and soccer
um but fast forward to
to university i didn't really want to
get into computers it wasn't my thing my
dad was an entrepreneur
so i went into business i've got a
commerce degree at ryerson university
um so i did never wanted to be the
developer but wanted to be
the person that would be working with
developers and and the problem solver i
mean my dad instilled on me very early
on
the asking of why for anything like
why is it like that is there a better
way to do things that just was the
nature of him
uh he's he's an inventor uh he's
he's got a number of patents in the
sport of curling which he kind of
transformed
um so just just growing up with that and
the questioning of why and
driving you nuts until you have a good
answer or until you can figure out a
better way to do things that's always
been instilled with me so
i went to school university in the 90s
business as i said and then went to work
for the family business which was
sliding patio doors manufacturing in
in the 2000s so my dad and his brothers
had a company
about 120 employees and uh
worked there got a lot of knowledge from
that along the way i
started a few different companies my
first business was actually the 90s
doing web design and graphic design
with html one when that first came out
but
after working for the family business my
my my dad
decided to retire and sell the business
and i had an opportunity to do something
that i
wanted to do and he asked me what i
wanted to do and i said i want to do
something technology focused and
something green because this was really
the
start around 2008 2007 there was a lot
of a lot of talk and incentives for
people to put in green technologies
especially here in canada and i got into
geothermal drilling
it was uh i bought this massive drill
from from italy
and proceeded to to drill holes hundreds
of feet into the ground with my drilling
team
to heat and cool buildings and we
started with two ikeas in italy and then
brought it over back to canada here and
started doing
commercial jobs condos um retirement
centers houses
basically using the earth's temperature
to keep them cool keep cool buildings
and
that was my first uh time there that i
realized when government kind of started
getting in the way with things and they
started instituting a whole bunch of red
tape and made it difficult and timely to
have to do a lot of the stuff that we
needed to do and it ended up the market
ended up diminishing
uh just because of the the interference
that was that that came about from that
and also working with drillers which are
a whole other animal
but in 2011
decided to sell a couple properties that
i that i had bought and looking at what
had happened in the us and the housing
crisis
and the banking crisis i kind of thought
we'd run into the same issue here up in
canada
we didn't but from 2005 to 2011 i did
quite well with the properties i had so
i ended up selling my properties and i
had this cash
that's when i heard about bitcoin this
was in 2012
in the summer 2012 and i kind of took my
my background in computers and
entrepreneurship
and um and economics because i've been
studying economics since 2009 a few
years and got down the the austrian
uh you know rabbit hole of a different
way of thinking of economics and
and it kind of all culminated when i
heard about bitcoin and
i couldn't utilize the internet when it
came about i was a little too fresh
though that's when i was going to
university but
it really was a perfect storm when when
when i heard about bitcoin and knew all
about the centralized technologies and
and just it made so much sense in the
right way i got it right away
i was up for weeks just devouring me and
catching up and
got in around 10 bucks was my first
initial investment
so that's kind of the short form of how
i got into tech and gone into this and i
started to think about what i could do
that was
taking my skills to create value in the
space and
uh looked for a community there wasn't
any and i started the toronto bitcoin
meetup group in 2012
and that was my way of saying
hey there's no community here i'm going
to build it and if you
can bring people together and people
interested and excited about a certain
theme or technology or or idea um
then you really become a center of
gravity and things start coming together
so that's really what i'm
you know pretty proud of was bringing
together the community here in toronto
um my first meet up metallic butter and
showed up and peter todd showed up
and that was really the the genesis of
the toronto
scene that started out so uh we grew to
you know uh from 10 people to meet up to
hundreds to
doing conferences and we've done about
120 events since then
since 2012. so that was the start
so when you first see bitcoin you've got
some cash uh from the properties
why buy bitcoin like was it hey i'm
going to buy this thing it's going to go
up
a bunch and i'm going to sell it for a
profit uh was it
you know i want to uh protect my wealth
what was kind of the the genesis of the
idea to actually make the investment
in my journey through economics uh from
what happened studying the the
the what happened in the u.s and it kind
of was sparked for my brother getting me
to
to look into what money really is he
he's like
study the history of money and i started
doing that and started understanding
things more and
i came across peter schiff and
peter schiff you know predicting the
housing crisis predicted the banking
crisis
um and and i started uh started
listening to his podcast and it's a
funny story i mean i mean
i i i'd like to say through space one
day if it wasn't for you peter i never
would have gotten involved in crypto
because it really if it wasn't for him
and he's an anti obviously an
anti-crypto person
but he kind of got me down the path of
of you know you got to be a value
creator you got to do things that uh
an entrepreneur and being a business
owner and hiring people and that's
that's that's really how you create
value and
and freedom and i've always been on a
hunt for freedom i
never liked school i never i never like
being told what to do
so why did i get into it because
it just made sense to me i the
technology side of it made sense the
economic side of it makes sense
because i almost throw my hands up in
the air i studied economics and new tech
is like here's the problem
this this this these systems of booms
and busts this inflation this this it's
increasing the money supplies
and the government getting involved in
things that that that lead to trying to
pick these winners and losers is really
really really a problem but what do you
do about it and that was like the
perfect timing to hear about
this this decentralized technology that
enabled people to be their own bank and
you could uh do things without needing
these intermediary level layers that
didn't really provide any value and
it just made so much sense to me and i
connected the dots
and i you know didn't put a lot in at
the time i think i put about eight
thousand dollars in around ten bucks
time and and it started
it wasn't it wasn't a big investment for
me really it but it started me
um you know just just learning and
figuring out how can i create value in
here and then started
in the meetup groups and getting people
together ideas just started flowing and
coming in
and i started doing a gambling site so
me and me and uh
my partner steve from uh who i connected
with on reddit back in 2012 he was a
developer i had business ideas we said
hey let's do something quick to make
some cash and then we can do something
more meaningful so
we we started up uh based on what eric
had done with with satoshi dice we
created a more graphical
uh game that only took bitcoin and ended
up
exiting for a few thousand bitcoin a few
months later for that so
we we achieved what we wanted to which
was let's do something that can get us
some capital to do something more
meaningful
and we did that and and that money
that that exit that i did and then plus
my investments ended up being the
initial funding for ethereum
that's that's how we were able to get
that off the ground without needing the
initial capital from the
crowd sale we did about it you know a
number of months later
so it was those kind of two things that
that was able to get
to get ethereum off the ground and get
that funded before we ended up
selling to the to the general public and
and and collecting the the larger
amounts
so when you first see bitcoin uh and you
start to put some of your own capital
in uh there's a lot of people who did
that and who sold along the way
and they said hey i bought it at you
know ten dollars and went to 20 and they
sold and i'm a genius and you know
then it kind of does what it did uh why
keep
investing more and more and more and
keep building and kind of like doubling
down
was it that as the price even though it
was super volatile it kind of kept
moving up into the right over longer
periods of time that gave you the
confidence
was it something else was it just the
community you had built in toronto like
it's very rare to be
that early in something and remain so
heavily convicted
uh you know and press it so hard
um over the years when i get into
something i really go hard into it
um and i just i've always been a long
holder
i'm not someone who plays the markets i
i'm not a trader
uh i just believe in the fundamentals of
it and i believe if it's not gonna be
something like bitcoin there's me
something else that's like bitcoin
that's gonna be providing the value that
people want and
i'm by no means means a maximalist of
anything i i like
choice i think what people want to use
is great so i'm very inclusive
to things and i've i spread it around
with what i'm doing and if
it's something that i believe and i'll
put some money into it um
so i just it's rare you're right i i
know
andreas antonopoulos has always said
that everybody has that
that that that thing where they dismiss
it at first and then they actually pick
it up later i
i i didn't do that i literally from the
day that i heard about my
first bitcoin the day that i actually
heard about it and i found some on local
bitcoin and got it
and then it just just didn't stop i
really go heavy into things and that's
what i've done and i've done it since
and it's had its roller coasters but
i'm just a long-term i just i just it's
not short term for me i believe
fundamentals with it
i believe in its utility i believe it's
going to take time
um but i i'm just i have no doubts
you know where i think this is going to
head and who knows you know necessarily
what technologies
will be the winners of it but i i just
think in general the the tech itself
and the idea of empowering people with
the tools they need to be in control of
their lives
is really what what made it for me and
that's why i build what i build and
we build interfaces that connect all
these technologies and wallets that
people can send and receive value
and that's just i like the build i like
to create
and that's just part of my my nature is
being creative and solving problems and
doing things that aren't normal in the
way that they're normally done
and figure out how to do things better
and it's it's
i can't imagine myself doing anything
else for the last eight years um
it's just it just made sense to me for
sure and then walk us through when you
decided that you guys should start
ethereum kind of what was the thought
process there and
just walk through kind of that story
quickly sure so
i when i when i exited the in 2013 from
the gambling site
we realized we had a wall me and my
partner started building walls because
we realized that's really akin to the
the browser for the internet is the
wallet for crypto you need that
interface that the mass is used and
that's what the wallet does so
started building that uh along the way
the talent was
helping me out with with companies
called cryptokit at the time
and uh he was assisting with a few
things and then i got connected with
charles hoskinson and he was doing the
bitcoin education project back in the
day in 2013 and
i was doing stuff for the bitcoin
alliance of canada a national non-profit
organization that i'd set up and so we
got connected
and along the way got to know metallic
as he was traveling around the world
i would go to conferences he would be
there he was interviewing me for bitcoin
magazine which
we've been writing for and and then
it just made sense when he showed me the
white paper in november of 2013.
um a lot of it was over my head actually
and
i needed someone to kind of validate it
for me and and
charles was a perfect person so i showed
her to charles hoskinson um
connected him with metallic and then and
then two other people
mihai ali say who was uh vitalik's
partner at pikmin magazine
and amir chatrides um the five of us
came together and and
we became the first five founders and
set everything up and
i got it off the ground uh eventually i
added a few more founders and
jeffrey wilkie and gavin wood and joseph
rubin
uh and that was the core eight and and
it just was was very early on
understanding that that
there was more than bitcoin now and that
was something that i didn't really get
until ethereum came along was that
there's going to be more of these
there's many more powerful things than
bitcoin
and the idea of bringing smart contracts
into play with this
is going to add so much more value in
many other sectors and many other things
that
then it just that made sense to me and
we just decided to go for it and
i dropped kind of working on the wallet
company for a while
and we just went went full on into
getting that off the ground and
started getting a lot of attention with
it and uh yeah the rest is history with
that
yeah and so when you think about um kind
of the world outside of bitcoin right i
think
bitcoin has been covered incredibly well
uh you've been around literally since
the inception of
of that market what do you see today as
the opportunity there right there's a
lot of people who say hey
it's bitcoin bitcoin only nothing else
matters there's a whole bunch of other
people who say no
this technology this decentralization
idea uh can be brought to every market
um just walk us through just
philosophically
uh at a high level how do you look at
everything other than bitcoin at the
moment and where we are
so i i'd like to say that that that
everything we deal with is digital it's
ones and zeros it's information
whether it's something digital in terms
of an asset uh with value or it's
it's a it's an email it's all digital
ones it's all it's all digital
and and anything digital or anything
that's information wants to be free
that's just my my stance on things and
anything you try to restrict or anything
you try to fight
it's a losing battle so i believe that
um we've got so many people working on
this technology now it's
it's i've lost a little bit of my mojo
for the space
um i think it's it's it's in great hands
now
and it's getting to the point that i was
would only hope that that would get to i
mean
look what we've got we've got we've got
tesla putting
it it's really mind-blowing we were
thought a few years ago what's happened
what's actually happening right now i
still think it's just the beginning
i think the impact is going to be felt
in in pretty much every every sector
um i think that uh
a lot of stuff is still i mean it's it's
not it's not binary you got a lot of
hype still going on you got the nft
stuff that's going on that kind of
reminds me what's going on with the ico
craze
back in the day um there's there's
there's a lot more receptiveness i mean
i was speaking with the
doing a government thing for the uae
today there's just a lot more
receptiveness and people are
understanding that it's going to be a
big part and if you're
a country or government that's that's
looking to to
do what you should be doing which is
which is getting getting ahead of the
curve and seeing how you can
distinguish yourself from other
countries and learning about and
educating yourselves
um i think that's that's where we're
where countries and i'm hoping uh ones
that really stand aside are gonna are
gonna do that
on the regulatory side and it's it's the
common
common stuff about you know you're going
to shoot yourself in the foot if you try
to do things that are going to
hinder and innovation and the technology
so the countries that do figure this out
are going to
leapfrog in excel and then they're gonna
be the ones in demand so
i mean it's it's it's it's gotten to the
point right now i think that it's it's
in really good hands to let this take
off and go
and for me i think it's gonna be majorly
impactful but it's it's
i'm looking more to other things right
now or myself
um but it's it's amazing really how it's
come along this far
for sure and so when you think about uh
let's say the last
you know five to seven years uh
basically since uh
ethereum uh really came on the scene and
then a number of these other
projects have uh failed but also there's
a ton of projects that have succeeded so
far in terms of the price of
uh or the market cap of those networks
what's your evaluation in terms of are
we in
the first inning are we maybe okay we
get some good models now and now we're
getting into more of the
the uh ability to replicate and keep
sustainable networks up
uh are we near the finish line and we've
done a bunch of innovation and there's
not likely much more to come
like how do you just evaluate where we
are in the evolution of this and the
adoption
still yeah still first inning um
most people in the world still don't
have a clue about what to do with this
or how to
how to utilize it uh we're just we're
just very early on my focus has always
been to
try to get to the masses everything i
build is for my dad to be able to use it
and that's what i think is needed the
interfaces the experiences
are needed for the average person to to
dig in like they did when they had the
internet browser they're like okay i can
now navigate this thing
it makes kind of sense to me we're just
we're just so early on and unfortunately
most people i think throw their hands up
and just don't even get involved because
they just don't know what to do when
they don't have the trusted sources
there's no
the leadership needs to really stand up
and be able to have the tools in place
for
the average person to know where to go
because you can just get lost in this
stuff
and and i think most people do and
since the rise over the last couple of
months you know i see my networks come
that aren't in the crypto space
hey i'm hearing about this what what do
i do i don't know where to go
it's a big problem and i think most
people just kind of tune it out because
they're just lost
so i think we're very early on until we
have the right interfaces and the right
experiences for the average person to be
able to go in and see that they've got
some value in here
and even if it is just to to invest a
bit or just to
put something in it but i just think
we're still super early on and it's
because of the complexities of the space
and it's complexities of the
technologies and there's just
so many different things out there and
difficult for people to navigate so
um i think once the education and the
places that people the average person
can go and start utilizing and getting
their hands a little dirty
is is when i'm gonna say it's a little
probably past the first thing but i
still think it's just we're just
super early on right now and that's okay
yeah one of the ideas that i've been
thinking a lot about there's just not
that many people to
talk about it um is crypto wealth
right so by my calculation if you take
let's say the forbes 400
uh list and you were to take many of the
people who are well known in the crypto
industry
uh and you were to rank them there
there's a number of people who would be
in that top 50 or that top 100
and as uh kind of the adoption of these
technologies continues
i think that you know there's a very
good chance that i don't know 20 25
of that list could be folks from one
specific industry
uh how do you think uh about that does
is that normal is that something that uh
people should be paying more attention
to does that
add more responsibility to the industry
just like
that that's something that seems like an
outlier and so how do you see that given
you just been around for so long
uh and seen this play out well there's
going to be
it's not going to be the same people
that are that are in those groups you're
going to have builders you're going to
have people that just bought and held
you're gonna have different
range of people that are that are doing
different things with that wealth
um but it does take some smarts to also
have it and hold on to it and get it to
where you are so i'm hoping the majority
of those people are gonna be the
builders the creators of problem solvers
that can then utilize that capital in
much more meaningful ways and
and and be able to understand some of
the the problems that the world is
facing right now and then be able to
take that wealth
and do it in in ways that are going to
be serviced to other people and solve
problems and do great things
so that's my hope is that you have a
majority of people in that group
that are builders that are creators that
have figured things out and have done
well in that space and they're just
going to continue to keep building and
i'm hoping that that's the majority but
i don't know what the breakup is with
those things
but i am hoping and optimistic that
that's that's going to be that that
wealth
does get into doing bigger things and
better things and
and i've seen it i've seen transitions
of people where you get to a certain
point it's like okay
what am i really doing here why am i
doing what i'm doing and figuring out
the you know your what your why in your
how
was kind of the biggest thing for me and
i think i think getting anybody to kind
of think about what is
why am i really doing what i'm doing and
and and why
sorry how like what is it that i that i
should be doing and why am i doing and
that and how am i
those are the the three kind of critical
questions that that get asked i think
and that
when you get to a certain point like
okay i've got everything that i need how
can i do something a little bigger
how can i do something that's going to
make some real big impact and what makes
me happy
and how do i do that so uh
that's that those are the types of
people i'm hoping and i know a lot of
them that are
in those groups where they could be
listed in the top 50 and that and those
are the people that i'm seeing that are
transitioning or feel the sense that
they're going more to a service role
which is really where i think is that's
that's my what it's a bit of service
and and and and it makes me happy to be
of service to people and that's my why
and then and then the house is the
problem solving and that's what i'm good
at
and and utilizing my formulas to solve
problems and
and that's how i'm going to carry out
those the b of service thing so
um i i think it's going to be different
i think we're we're
it's not the same in our space as it
would be in a traditional setting where
you're making the wealth
but at least for my network it's also
about
you know where they're they have they
have the the
intelligence and they have this the
different capitals you need the trust
capital you need the wealth capital
knowledge capital all these things that
you need together in order to actually
create
some big change so i'm optimistic that
you're going to see some different
people emerging from this that are that
are going to be problem solvers and
really take that wealth that they're
bringing together and and the skills and
the tools that they've been able to do
to create some really great things
before we get into what you're building
with decentral uh well how do you think
of your portfolio right in terms of uh
non-crypto assets crypto assets and then
uh
also inside of crypto any sort of
breakdown between bitcoin
ether uh and everything else is there
kind of just ballpark
uh percentages uh in terms of how you
can structure your portfolio
yeah uh so so previously over the from
2017
when i was in 2018 early 2018 where i
did most of my investments
um i was able to get into some really
early chinese projects like vechain and
quantum i was one of the initial
investors in two of those projects
um and then you know initially was
bitcoin then bitcoin funded ethereum and
then ethereum enabled me to fund bigger
things that i that i did
really well with now i've kind of fallen
back to just
simplicity um i'm in a number of
different projects but majority of my
stuff is in the top the top projects so
the top
few um i'm a big fan of polka dot
i'm a big fan of um uh of cardano
a big fan of charles let's say that um
you know taking some different
approaches in the way that they're doing
things much more on the academic side of
what he's done and bringing stuff
forward but
i'm really really big fan of gavin wood
and and knowing those guys from the days
back of ethereum and knowing their drive
and knowing their competitiveness
and their smarts um i was able to kind
of see those projects for the last few
years and
and and know that they were going to get
to where they they've gotten up to so
most of my stuff is in the top few
things ether bitcoin uh
cardano polkadot i like cosmos as well
um and there's a few others but i'm not
getting lost in a lot of the d5 stuff
um i just think there's not enough time
and energy
and a lot of these it's a full-time gig
to be running a lot of that stuff and
keeping on top of stuff so i've
simplified my life but a bit
over the last few years um and
you know that that's what i've got my
portfolio for everybody else to be
different i don't like to tell people
what to invest in or what to do
but um that's kind of where i've gotten
i've also got you know i've got real
estate
and and some other things outside of the
crypto space that i'm into i'm also into
uh you know sustainable food um grows uh
a number of things outside of the crypto
space too
and so when you think about uh the
non-crypto side
uh would you say more of your wealth in
crypto or not in crypto
um most of my i'm i'm i'm more crypto
now given the
where the markets have gone uh but real
estate was
was was for me higher up the you know
over the last couple years i did make
some sizable investments in real estate
and then i have a number of other of
other investments um crypto non-crypto
that i don't even know what some of them
are worth right now because the
a lot of them were in a 2017 2018 and
they're now just starting to
to get going with some things so yeah i
would say i'm probably
uh crypto non-crypto and real estate
probably pretty even the reason why i'm
asking
is uh it's it's fascinating to me to see
uh people who made wealth outside of
crypto
come into crypto the people who made
wealth in crypto do they actually want
to diversify out of crypto in some cases
and uh i don't see a pattern yet it
literally is uh
very very different for for different
people and so uh i'm watching it just
because i think it'll be interesting
you know if you kind of think of
traditional investors kind of 60 40
portfolios
really we're kind of the standard for a
long time uh does that happen
in crypto is there some sort of whether
it is portfolio construction
um among the top assets or some sort of
uh
commonality between non-crypto and
crypto type portfolios
i just i don't see a trend yet there's
also other factors too like liquidity as
well so
in my real estate stuff i when when
ether was about 100 bucks
i i knew it was getting back up to its
highs and i was like i'm going to just
dump everything back into crypto
but going through the sales doing this
it's too much friction to get that done
and i didn't end up doing it but if i
had it right then and if i could have
moved it into crypto
back uh january of last year when i
started seeing
you know this is this is now i feel
we're getting back into things right now
i think ether is going to hit it's it's
high in the next 12 months 18 months
um if i had that liquidity i would have
put it all in the crypto back then
i did make those picks back then but i
didn't and now it's gone up and i'm like
i'll just leave my real estate alone
right now
that can that can do anything but
there's no set thing i just
whatever i kind of feel whatever the gut
feeling is to me and i just feel we're
just
still so early on with this here um
that it would be kind of silly for me
sometimes to not move stuff more into
crypt if i feel like it's going to be
going to have a much higher return than
some other stuff absolutely makes that
makes complete sense
tell me about the central and kind of
what you guys should build there and jax
sure so uh decentral's a company
it was uh kind of the the idea of having
a place in toronto
where i could do my meetups so i got a
building and that's kind of where
ethereum started out with and started
running meetups and i called it bitcoin
decentral
i didn't want to call it bitcoin central
they just didn't seem to fit the ethos
of
of bitcoin so i kind of coined the
neuron the term decentral
and this was right when we were starting
ethereum so
bitcoin decentral only lasted a few
months because then i got rid of the
bitcoin and just called it decentral
because i kind of covered everything
so decentral's been around since uh 2014
uh we i out amalgamated a few bunch of
my bunch of my companies into one in
2017 but but our main product is is jax
liberty
and it's a jax is a is a wallet that uh
multi-currency multi-platform interface
that
supports about 12 main net coins a bunch
of different tokens
uh we've got news and pricing and
portfolio
and sending receipt to the networks and
managing your crypto it's all
non-custodial so the users are in full
control of the keys that's part of our
our ethos is we never want to hold or
have access to customer funds
um it's a it's a self-funded
um company i don't take outside capital
with anything that i do i just
i don't i don't like to be constrained
by having to provide returns to
investors and it enables me to go the
speed that i want
um it enables me to not have to focus on
on investors as well and things so it's
enabled me to really be
more flexible and i have to do things at
the pace i want
and um we we identified early on
all the things the internet needed the
new decentralized world was going to
need
so it needed a browser which was the you
know the
internet needed netscape it needed the
first initial browsers it needed cloud
services so the tools that connect to
the chains
it needs partnerships and app stores so
that's always been our goal and our goal
is to build all of the pieces that
the internet needed in the new
decentralized world and
we've kind of along the way built the
browser which is jack's liberty the
interface
we've built the the cloud services which
is our infrastructure that we built that
connects to all the chains and that's
something that that we built from
scratch and something that we're
eventually gonna
open up and allow others to start using
um we have the partnerships
that we've that we brought into our
interface so that that the users can do
the services that they want so it's
really an ecosystem that we built with
jax liberty and
over the years it's garnered quite a bit
of trust uh we're in 220 plus countries
um because we don't have cool customer
funds we don't have the regulatory
burdens
of a normal company would in having to
do kyc and aml for their users because
we just don't
actually hold your money so we've never
taken custodianship
and then we use partners to facilitate
all services so we're a very small lean
team of just a few people
um we've had millions of people download
our products over the years
and now we're just starting in the
growth mode so our infrastructure
was revamped over the last couple years
it's now scalable interoperable it's
the best thing that we've ever seen
anybody create in order to connect to
these chains
and now we're finally after eight years
going into
into user user acquisition mode and
that's kind of exciting this year is
is we've been really low key in just
making sure our infrastructure and
everything is is ready to support
uh without without a dime spent on any
type of user acquisition
um over the last number of years we're
doing between two and seven thousand new
users a day
um there's billions of dollars being
managed in jax that our users are
managing right now themselves not with
us
holding it but they build it um and now
i think the sky's the limit once we
start
working with our external teams on on
growth on getting all our data and
acquisition information put together pr
all that stuff's now coming together and
i think people are gonna start seeing us
us more as we finally now can feel
comfortable enough transitioning into
into into telling our users now you know
check out what we've built over the
years we've got
we think we have a really good user
experience it's an all-in-one app
you really don't need to do to go
outside of the app you can buy your
crypto you can trade your crypto in
there be our partners
it's really a good ecosystem right there
and um
the acquisition we do have right now is
all been through i think word of mouth
because i can't see how else other you
know thousands of people every day are
coming
and using us with us also not not doing
any outreach
at all so i think we built the trust up
and now we can start uh working to grow
and scale it and getting it
because it's a tool i believe that the
average person can utilize
to get into the space and i think those
are the tools that are needed
yeah and so when you think about um
kind of the use case for this right uh
if you are able to build this
all-in-one ecosystem where people come
in they can buy they can store
uh they can kind of use uh the assets uh
what's the 20-year vision right in terms
of if you own the deposit if you own
kind of the payment the transaction
uh in your ecosystem there's all kinds
of different things you can do do you
have any idea what direction you want to
take it
uh over kind of a decade or two yeah i
think that
um well my goal is to sell the company
um i have some other things that i that
my mind has been going more towards that
i wanna i wanna do but in order to do
that i need to maximize the value of
this to have the wealth that i need in
order to do some of the the larger
problem solving stuff i want to do
so i don't have a longer term horizon
right now
the idea that i've always had for the
product and for the company was to
again be the browser be the cloud
services be everything that you need in
one
in one interface that that the masses
can use but it's also
it outlives us as well because people
can always take their keys and go into
another platform and that's part of what
we built too because we wouldn't want
everybody just have to rely on us too
so that's another kind of ethos of the
company is to make sure it survives
ourselves too
but the vision i did have was to have
thousands of partners to have this major
ecosystem where people are
using our key system to to encrypt their
passwords like lastpass or
uh being able to to to do their loans
everything any any anything any sector
that
that you can use with with smart
contracts and you can use right now in
crypto
and that's going to be every sector we
we were going to the plans to be that
hub it's to be that place that you can
do all of that
and it's all wrapped around
decentralized identity communication
um and money those are really the three
pillars we've built on
um and that's what we offer and that's
that's where i believe everybody should
be
in control of those things we we don't
collect user information
that we believe that should be held by
the user not us we don't do advertising
there's no
revenue streams there that are directing
people down a path to buy something
which i think is one of the
biggest problems the world has with
technology and these models of
of making money or leading to this this
degradation of
and tribal mentalities that we're seeing
with people all because
you're being let down a path to buy
something and that's what people don't
understand and that's where a lot of
this
this um fake news out there and
it gets people's emotional attachments
to go do something and that's
unfortunate to start seeing this this us
versus them mentalities that are out
there and
it all comes down to me this is models
and those business models need to be
changed and that's kind of where my mind
goes more to is how do we shift the
incentive structures from people away
from this
maximizing shareholder turn to creating
positive impact and
helping others and being of service to
others and that'll get you what you want
not the other way around
um so that's where my mind goes but as
as
the company and as i would love to see
jax be as is the go-to
place that empowers people to be
controlling or digitalized that's that's
that's what we build
your money your communication and and
your your identity should be in your
hands and you decide how that gets
utilized
and not via other people making money on
that
for sure um when you think about
corporations or
entities i know you've got a bunch of
ideas around maximizing shareholder
value
versus maybe optimizing for other
opportunities
the whole idea of changing incentives
just kind of share some of your thoughts
there and
and why this is important to you and
what you think can change
sure so as a technologist i just like to
say i
think technologies are our biggest
concern i think the models that most
people use the business models about
maximizing shareholder returns
every month having to you have these
investors that have put their faith and
money into you
um and they're expecting and you're
obligated to provide them a return
and along the way a lot of companies
their their initial goals and motives
and and what they wanted to do ends up
getting passed aside because now they're
they have to do what's maximizing
towards their shoulders
and that's where i think they start
diluting others from the equation and
stakeholders that
that you end up turning into enemies or
you start they start realizing that by
them
looking for more money or striving for
more money um
there's people that are being discluded
here or that drive
is coming at expense of the planet it's
coming up expense of other people
and and it it it's it comes from not
being able to think
harder on trying to do a better model
it's my opinion it's the lack of problem
solving capabilities and be able to say
these business models don't work and
i've recognized this for eight years
we've been building stuff
you know not based on collecting user
information or not based on
um maximizing returns or shareholders or
not based
on uh advertising models because i i
recognize those are those are faulty
models that are going to lead to
situations like we see now we see it
the models of the facebooks the googles
and they don't want to single that it's
just
that's what they know that's what
they've only known they've known
i collect i i have information or i sell
to advertisers and now
i'm i'm beholden to them and i have to
to give them
returns so i need to to direct our
customers to do these things that
appease these people
and these these these these customers or
users
are are are being guided
to do things that they're not even aware
half the time that they're doing and
that's kind of the most nefarious stuff
and that's that's what a lot of these
models like is that we're going to get
you to do something you don't even know
you do it
and that's what we are seeing is people
that are not sophisticated enough
being led by advertiser models
advertiser models
to to some type of goal that that
advertiser wants you to do
and they're not sophisticated enough to
understand that they're being led
down something that that that is that
has a different motive there
and and that frustrates me because it's
taking advantage of people that don't
know any better
and and this is leading to um not just a
problem with people's information
getting exposed
and the models of the hacks that come
about from centralized systems that are
storing
massive amounts of people information
and credit card numbers
but what's even worse than that is is is
is the
this this this these zombie-like states
that people are going into
uh and reading things that are contrary
to their beliefs or they go down a path
and they go down a rabbit hole and now
their emotions are tied to this journey
and it's all because
at the end end game is for you to go and
do something that's going to put some
more money in someone's pocket
and they're not sophisticated enough to
understand that they're going down that
path so
my kind of my thesis in this whole thing
is that
it's the incentive structures of the
world are misaligned they're misaligned
and
leading to the problems that we have and
there's a solution to it i believe which
is to showcase that
the more energy the more people we can
get towards creating and being a service
and creating
positive results for more people the
more you can spearhead movements towards
towards identifying stakeholders and
creating wins for stakeholders by
problem solving and thinking beyond the
normal models
that's how you create movements and
those that bring people together
and those that showcase that if i'm
helping and being of service to others
they will join me because them joining
me helps them
and the more people will realize that if
we can shift towards
impact and shift our thoughts and even
our companies and our brains
towards creating good for people that's
what the people want and you'll get your
return in spades by doing that
not and but it takes the brain power to
think about it
not the general model of we got to make
more money we don't care who
who's at the expense of who we're going
to do things the way that we've always
done it
and why are these people unhappy with
this well they're not happy because
you're disclosing them you're not
figuring out how to create
win-win-win-win-wins for everybody
so i've spent a few years building a
problem solving models that i
that's that i'm hoping i can spearhead
this change towards
this shift towards uh creating
compounding impact
and by doing that you will get the the
returns that you want and your
shareholders want
by becoming a brand or an icon that is
helping others and and that's how i
think we're going to start
distinguishing the icons of the world
those that are really stepping forward
and showing leadership and bringing
people together on common things that
help more people out and that's how i
think you create movements so
that's where my passion lies and that's
what i want to be doing in the future
is is is providing that plan for that
shift and actually showcasing that that
will work and that's that's the way to
do things
for sure and so how do people do that in
practice right like the
the mission is uh admirable uh it's very
clear
it's very obvious kind of uh what the
idea is but if you're running a business
today what is like the practical
application of it or what can you do
today uh start moving in that direction
so for me it all comes back to to my
formulas
to solve problems and though the
formulas that i have
kind of they are unique they identify
they bring in stakeholders that you
wouldn't even think would be in your
problem it tries to add as many
stakeholders as possible
and then it works and i and i use the
you know
my ability to be able to piece
everything together to figure out and
not stop until all stakeholders have a
win
as a general company though what what
the world is lacking is a lot of
leadership a lot of problem-solving
capabilities
so part of my plan is to release the
formulas that i that i'm putting in i've
got into a paper right now i call it
perfect formula
and and it all revolves around the
concept of win-win wins and identifying
as many stakeholders and creating
movements by bringing people together
so for me it's the model that i've been
putting together that i think will be
the first step for people understanding
here's a new way of looking at problem
solving
and if you can utilize this model to
solve problems like i've utilized them
in the past it's going to give you and
your company an opportunity to figure
out how to create wins for more people
than you would ever think you could
so it's a lot of people are are maybe
operating at a 20
formula that they're using but they're
just excluding 80 of the stakeholders
that they should be able to bring into
the mix and create wings for
so a lot of companies just don't have
the brain power the problems on the
capabilities to do that
they know the models that they know they
just don't have
the the skill set and the tools to be
able to think beyond that
and that's kind of where i can come into
play and not just me but i like to call
my superhero network of problem solvers
this crypto space is full of problem
solvers and
it's not just about the crypto space the
crypto thing is kind of one tool in my
tool belt
there's there's so much more i think
that that needs to be explored not just
for me but others that are doing these
amazing things in the spaces
you're problem solvers and the ability
to tackle a problem
if you've got trust capital social
capital all the different wealth capital
knowledge capital all these capital
things
tools that people can put together that
i think i've tried to put together over
the years
and then if i can bring in others that i
know in my network so the social capital
that i have to be able to descend on a
problem
and showcase new ways of doing things um
so preliminary right now i think it'd be
difficult for for an entity to
to to to switch or to say here i
understand what you're saying but how do
i need that pan and that plan in that
path
that's what i'm developing first and
that's the first thing that's going to
come out as a paper on perfect formula
and how the problem solving metric can
be utilized
so that you can be a company or a brand
or a person
and utilize this in order to get what
you want and that's usually about
empowering people
you're it's it's the tools to empower
people to
monetize or to to if you're an icon
monetize your career or
or be able to utilize and activate your
fans together on a common goal of
creating good for other people so
more of my of my my my structure
and my framework i'll be bringing out
and releasing you get a clearer picture
of what it is the different stages and
the different things the problem-solving
format
formula um so but right now it's
like say one thing it's it's try to
figure how you can add as many
stakeholders to your problem as possible
and figure out a way to create wins for
those stakeholders because the more
people you add and the more people
you're creating wins for the more people
will be on your side
so if you are a brand or a company it's
how are you creating positive impact in
your users lives or how are you
attracting new people because you're
solving their problems
everybody's got a problem everybody has
a problem and is looking for a guide
with a plan so
how can you be that guy with a plan
that's that's that's that's
solving people's problems and day-to-day
problems so that would be i think one
one thing let's say is is bring in more
stakeholders and figure out how you can
create
create wins that impact their day-to-day
lives and get them alongside
your mission whether you're a company or
brand or what it is along with what
you're doing because
by them joining you their life gets
better yeah
when you think out you know 50 years
from now
what do you want your legacy to be
i don't know that's that's a that's a
hard one um my mission right now is
again to be of service
to people and i'm utilizing perfect
formula to do that that's my
problem-solving capabilities to be a
service to as many people as i can is
what i'm doing um i think the incentive
structures are
the biggest problem the world has and i
think if i if i could be known for a
person that was
able to showcase the people there's a
better way of doing things there's a
better way
um to be incentivized not just by wealth
and by thinking of yourself and your
company you got to think of as many
people as possible so
if if ray daly was known for principles
i'd like to be known as the incentives
guy that is able to shift the incentives
of the world to positive impact and the
more you do of that the more you'll get
of the other stuff you're looking for
yeah
and so when you think uh about how
people can
uh do this if they don't run a company
what do you think about in terms of
how they can kind of chip in as well so
it's obvious the company
founders or or executive teams or the
people who
kind of have control power and influence
but how do everyday people
uh kind of participate alongside these
same ethos
i think i think constantly learning
constantly just have that drive for
knowledge
um connecting with people uh
there's there's there's there's kind of
two different classes i see there's the
people that that are
are understanding that that they they
need to to get ahead and to understand
they need to
take time and energy to do so and it
can't just be something that falls on
your lap
um when i was doing the meetups and
bringing people together it was really
the people that would that would go to
their day-to-day jobs then afterwards
they would come over and because they
were excited about something they're
interested in something they want to see
what's next what's coming up so
i think complacency is is is something
that that
challenges people a lot when when all of
a sudden one day they haven't kept up
with what's going on in their industry
or their sector
and they get hit over the head because
something's come along that's displaced
and they didn't see it coming it's like
well
you got to see this stuff coming there
is the you know
we're it's very competitive nature and
you have to
know and stay ahead of the curve and be
able to to keep learning and keep
striving to gain
so if you're someone in a company that's
working and
and you're looking to see how you can
help contribute or bring things to light
for the seniors um you know starting
starting groups your peers together
bringing people together around a
certain thing because then when you have
enough enough people together on an idea
or something then you can take it to
uh take it take it larger i mean i've
had a number of people in my meetups
that started
groups within their their companies
around crypto
um and that's had some pretty good
success of getting some you know whether
it be in a bank or whether it be
in in different areas um
bringing people together something
you're excited about uh getting strength
in numbers and then being able to
propose something or ideas to
to senior management that that um that
might make them you know consider and
diplomacy is always a big thing
for me it's not acting crazy uh there's
too many people that i've seen that have
gone on
on a mission or something and and they
won't get the people to listen to them
because they act like they're crazy
so doing something in a way that's going
to be diplomatic and it's going to
showcase to someone here's
here's something maybe you consider um
doing it in a way that's that's humble
in a way that that makes sense and has
been well thought through
all these things are going to get uh
people listening to you a little bit a
little bit more
um in a way than than than i've seen
that a lot of people do it
that doesn't lead to the good results
yeah
yeah yeah i completely agree before i
let you go i always ask everyone the
same three questions you could ask me
one question at the end
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
uh the daily story why
it's 365 meditations um from
philosophers
and it's something that i bought
numerous copies of that i give out to
people and it's something that i enjoy
reading because it's
i can read one page and each page is
kind of a meditation
it's a certain around a certain theme
with a quote from a philosopher
and an idea and a concept that i can
then think about that day
or sometimes what i'll do is i i do a
couple times a year i'll do like a seven
day silent retreat and i'll do a fast
and i'll take this book and i'll go
through the whole thing and i'll make
notes on it and it really
just keeps me grounded and i just love
the
the i just aligned with the ideas in it
and it's it's
it's it's it's got so many words of
wisdom from previous philosophers and
it's something that i that i
easy for me to say that's the number one
book
second question is more personal sleep
schedule i used to sleep five or six
hours
now i sleep like eight or nine and this
question comes from our friends over at
eight sleep who have a thermoregulated
bed
uh i sleep on this thing i turn it ice
cold and sleep like a baby now and it's
literally been life-changing
uh what is your sleep schedule and how
has that changed over time
so my ideal sleep schedule is what i
what i'm sticking to right now is i'm in
bed
by nine or ten and i get up at three
um i i from three to eight is my time
that's literally the time when i'm not
distracted um i can
put her around take care of my emails
get ready for the day
in a way that i'm not rushing on
anything um
it's it's something that i that's the
most important time for me is it's that
morning time to get myself set up for
the day and then eight o'clock rolls
around and i start focusing on
my team we do our stand-up in the
morning uh i'll take a nap from like two
to three
like a half an hour uh but but that's it
and and i found the most important thing
for sleeping
is the food that i eat uh the better
that i eat the less carbs i eat the less
sleep i need when i fast
uh within the second day i need half the
sleep
and there's just the digestion is so
taxing on the body
that if you're not putting if i'm not
putting the things that
that are good for the body and that can
go through pretty quickly
um i need to sleep more so the heavier
foods i eat leads a lot more sleeping
that i have to do so
um definitely a a leaner diet for me
helps me to not need as much sleep
and i'm pretty good with with you know
five or six hours
usually works pretty good for me yeah
that's awesome
uh last question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or non-believer
yeah i i don't know if we've ever seen
any but i just
the mathematics and the numbers just
doesn't make seem to make sense to me
that we're the only thing out there i
just
i just i just don't think it is but i
could be wrong with it
yeah i i agree i think they're out there
i don't know if we're going to come in
contact but uh but i agree
uh what one question you have for me to
uh to finish up
what was the what was your initial drive
for the show
to get this off the ground and what
you've done because you i don't have
hundreds of episodes you've done now but
you're doing like
almost one every day something like that
like it's just phenomenal it's the it's
the
in the amount of the amount of of you
know
attention that you're not attention but
what you've done for the space and bring
the light and bring all these people
together and have these conversations
it's just been phenomenal so what
initially started you and then that
first drive to get something like this
off the ground
uh literally a couple of guys came to me
and they said uh hey
you should start a podcast and i said i
don't even know how to do that what is a
podcast
and they were like you know we could do
it all all you have to do is walk in the
room and uh basically interview it later
found out
uh that mike and jason had no clue what
they were doing uh but they went home
and they googled a bunch and they
figured it out
uh so you know i respect anyone who
basically can do that
and uh we recorded three of them
released them and
uh people liked it so we just kept going
and it started out kind of one a week
and then two week three week and
now uh five a week and so we calculated
it the other day it's been about
two and a half years almost exactly uh
and so
uh we did 500 shows in two and a half
years which is basically releasing one
almost every 36 hours which is just a
crazy thing to think about when we look
in hindsight but you know
we're pretty efficient with it and so i
learned a lot i get to meet great people
uh and i think a lot of people enjoy
listening so we'll keep doing it
great well i enjoyed the conversation
immensely thanks so much for having me
on
for sure where can we send people to
find you uh either on the internet or
find more about the central
uh probably my twitter is probably the
best it's diorio anthony so at
d-i-i-o-r-i-o
anthony a-n-t-h-o-n-y awesome man listen
thank you so much for doing this uh
you've been around for a long time
and you're still building which i
appreciate so we'll have to do it again
in the future
thanks dad appreciate it see ya